another thing that's making everyone
think about is Kim Khloe Kardashian's uh
post that she did a few days ago got
people talking this weekend with her
photo she posted this take a look at her
new look given a moment take a moment
she's showing off her new hair color but
people thought she looked completely
different yeah so she captioned the
photos location under which his skin
will say but it's the word with Abby and
she's got lots of reaction including
from her ex I guess you call him her ex
Tristan Thompson who commented batty
with a heart emoji PS I'm all for the
caption and he's got firework fire bicep
and I guess like the grunting emoji I
guess I've never used that before looks
like I guess right yeah no so people so
yeah it was supposed to be a better hair
but people thought her overall
appearance looked very different
okay alright when you saw that photo
what was your reaction uh why I saw the
talk already like people were talking
about like her skin tone look different
looks like she's done some of your skin
but that's the thing I feel like one you
can't really tell if like maybe she just
put a weird filter on it that would just
slightly making her face look a bit
different
who knows could be the lighting it could
be the makeup that she has on plus he
says she looks like Denise Richards I
think she looks a lot like her sister
kendall Jenner
don't you see it with the eyes like like
do you think right no could it just be
like the eyebrows and the makeup she
looks amazing uh you know I've seen a
lot of post about how she's evolved over
the years in terms of her hair and her
face and her lips and her eyes a lot of
people doing a lot of comparison you
know if this is what she she feels best
in then it's great she looks beautiful
and it is it's a shocker to a lot of
people because she looks completely
different she does look different from
her last few photos and but she is a
gorgeous woman
and if this is what makes her happy and
maybe it is filters who knows I mean we
know this world the filters let's be
honest a lot of people use filters and
they change the way their face look you
can change the way your nose looks your
eyes your chin you go cheeks right hair
color everything even through isolation
I think you want to cover your whites
it's easy to do I don't know but the the
point is you know she looks very
different and I think she may
acknowledge it I have a feeling she will
come out and talk about this photo one
day soon because there's been such a
major reaction to it but she looks
amazing I mean and she looks at me she's
smiling yeah Morrell says the
Kardashians looked more beautiful before
as natural and even says she looks
amazing but I don't get why people these
days are always coming at celebrities
for the color of their skin or hairstyle
it's just a picture
Noah says my first reaction when I saw
Chloe South's me she looks of the bear
makeup she has on it's probably filtered
but who cares everyone uses filters Nell
says nobody that family is natural or
looks looks natural I will say I have
been thinking like nothing nothing
accusing Chloe of having work done but I
have been thinking
I bet you a ton of celebrities are
getting work done right now this is the
perfect time to get plastic surgery ever
because no one's gonna sing for weeks
it's really easy to disappear for a
while so I I think you're sure I'm sure
there's all good starters and figuring a
way to go see a doctor it's a good point
doctors that are still doing procedures
and stuff like whatever injections stuff
I bet a lot of you know it is a world
that we both don't know we don't
understand it but if that's what makes
people happy and then go for it and do
what you like to do but when you do post
some like that I mean there is this
whole article I read about if you are
taking that step acknowledge it and you
are gonna get remarks on it acknowledge
it I mean this is something that you
wanted to do and if you're in the the
limelight and you're putting it out
there you are gonna do something so many
sumption so talk about it it's something
that's important to you but hey I think
she was amazing again and that photo was
really exciting to see I mean a lot of
people did react to it but your hair
comment looks amazing